im rheinland-pfälzischen morbach ist die
örtliche turnhalle seit monaten wegen
corona geschlossen schulsport ist
verboten freizeitsport auch trotzdem ist
hier jeden morgen leben in der halle
täglich rückt eine putzkolonne amt und
reinigt die stillgelegte halle völlig
sinnlos aber jeden morgen wäre die
blitzblanke halle wieder aufs neue zum
strahlen gebracht
im großen und ganzen ist lachhaft dass
richtig lachhaft fließt also wirklich
nicht meine das sind steuergelder die da
drauf gehen das ist schon krass ja jetzt
gibt sachen diesem unfassbar ist
unerklärbar ist niemand in der lage
solche missstände irgendwie zu
regulieren
die morbacher wundern sich schon die
ganzen winter dass die turnhalle jeden
morgen festlich beleuchtet ist denn
sport ist hier ja verboten aber
pünktlich um halb sieben ist eine
putzkolonne im einsatz und wischt die
halle feucht durch jeden tag eine
reinigungskraft seubert ihr sage und
schreibe zweieinhalb stunden täglich
obwohl seit monaten gar nichts
verschmutzt wird in diesem gebäude im
hunsrück dürfte mittlerweile kaum noch
ein staubkorn zu finden sein kann man
irgendwo anders einsetzen sinnvoll
es gibt ja genug andere einrichtungen
dann muss sich der kreis gedanken machen
dann ist ja geld rausgeschmissen
verantwortlich für die sporthalle ist
der landkreis bernkastel-wittlich im
kreishaus verweist man darauf dass die
glas- und gebäudereiniger innung darauf
gepocht habe das reinigungs aufträge
bestehen bleiben schriftlich heißt es
dieser umstand ist im vertragsrecht
geschuldet die pandemie machte nämlich
lediglich eine nutzung der halle zu
sport zwecken unmöglich nicht aber deren
reinigung eine seit monaten verwaiste
sporthalle wird also völlig sinnlos
gereinigt weil es halt so auf dem papier
steht zweieinhalb stunden reinigung wird
die leute selbst die dort arbeiten
werden es genauso als wenig sinnvoll
erachten und man muss es einfach nicht
verstehen und sie ahnen es das große
reinigen geht weiter auch in den
kommenden wochen wird hier jeden morgen
gefeilt und geputzt
ein titel dürfte morbach damit nicht zu
nehmen sein
hier steht die wahrscheinlich sauberste
turnhalle deutschlands